đồng thời phát triển cho cho đi tử. Giám đốc cơ quan mật vụ Mỹ SON Keren cho biết,
không trong mắt lần đã vượt qua của book Kim Sara Ninh cho khi bị không trẻ,
đồng thời đánh ra cao ấy thống bảo vệ như lớp đã phát vý dựa qua,
mừng viên mật vụ bị bắn những đã qua cơ nuy giận như mặt áo trung đặt.
Theo công tổ viên liên bang Johnny Piro,
nghĩa phản lần đối mặt với các cá mục sử dụng sống trong hành vi bạo lực và tấn công sĩ qua liên bang.
Đồng thời có thể bị bộ suông thiên tổ xanh khi điều tra thi tổ.
Hẹn đối thường nằm bị giám sử vật dựa kiến hồ và liên bang và ngay hành bài thống tư tại Washington DC.
Tổng thống đơn trang cùng các quan trích cấp cao được xanh nhận an toàn.
Tổng trang sau đó đã cán lợi phản đứng của lực lượng mà vụ,
mà cho biết sự kiện sĩ đều tổ chức lại trong thời gian tựa.